welcome to this video playing your tune
from from Denmark please yep denmark and
we have an orang utan or wrong it
Orangatang orangutang yeah I cannot do
that ok 1b form don't see that too often
what I'm playing here is one of them
prescribed antidotes what he's playing
is really weird what on earth are you
doing yeah well if you play before you
need a very liberal sense of positional
subtleties funny hit Queen h5 takes on
c5 winning a prawn yeah of course I
didn't think about stuff like that
playing too quickly yeah yeah so g6 on
know right so I'm sacrificed and the
porn what what now it's not the end of
the world
but certainly not on what I intended
yeah how to how to get some play can can
try to sacrifice even more but it feels
like your sacrifice more it's like being
pawed committed in poker you need to
bluff even more and at the end you don't
have anything so what are you doing now
a 6a 6b five maybe yeah one problem of
this is not so much the pawn I mean this
is a problem the porn but it's also that
this bishop on f6 is just terrible it's
just a text t4 and doing nothing there
it's quite quite awful
I hope I can get something here on c4
some peace on c4 yeah the bad thing is
this even a for coming but a four-night
c4 maybe is okay
ok how to how to play this
hmm
caf it's basically just upon not not
much else yeah so be it moves I don't
know not taking this light-filled
strange to me okay he maybe wants to
still play a form okay let's put the
bishop p.m. so after a four I can take
on d2l a for getting a poem back huh
this was the idea quite ambitious but
maybe not bad
okay now while this isn't this isn't
great for black but at least I'm still
on the board it should be six Queen h4
maybe I can stay up some trouble on a
very good day this might work that may
be threatening to take the egg play
Queen d7 and c5 getting a pawn back and
you know here actually the question is
how to recapture I could take with the
bishop why not activating this piece a
bit at least now taking on c4 is pretty
much out of the question when I have the
chance to retake with them the bishop
I'm still threatening to take here yeah
okay this is
this is probably an just fine for black
at least this as possible but maybe
that's something else I do 92y this is
hanging okay let's grab this first is
some coordination problems here now how
to what's the best way into place is
completely tied here but what's the vest
that's some way to yeah maybe this one
in threatening rook e8 and keeping an
eye on the porn I mean it I'm playing
for an edge now what this was the idea
the main idea was routine I thought he
needed to play rookie one actually but
then Rukia 27 it's clear that that if
for was a mistake because because of
what happened but he probably should be
able to to keep it equal though yeah
this is this is already tricky and Queen
f8 is winning already hi nice Queen f-ed
winning I didn't see it when said I only
saw that it's the move tool to play and
rookie one is now the only move to
defend for a moment at least rookie one
rookie 822 queen e seven okay yeah but
it's a deadly pin the question is only
if I take it am i winning this is some
this is always a problem but maybe black
hand can improve I mean only take when
it's really suitable why it has no way
to get out of the pin anyway not quite
sure what move white should play now
some some 0 move now that I've even can
check here now widest busted compass on
minus minus 2 or something strange yeah
what he needs to do is probably avoid
you form and play some other moves so
just like just this for example I mean
it's still upon I think I made a bit of
a progress but it's the upon and not at
all easy comp gives white pretty decent
edge of about one pawn yeah so it's just
the body count here six against five
and should be enough for some hedge yeah
just just blended the pond to this
through this funny idea alright thanks
for watching